[Music]
bieber and his pals cruise around on
snowmobiles and hang out in a mountain
cabin giving us major canadian vibes a
lot of my songs recently have been kind
of heavy my last single was ghost and
it's about death and it's very heavy
topic and i think i wanted to
bring a side that was more
just less heavy more
um light and fun and
uh
just kind of a bounce
justin also tells siriusxm's pandora now
channel that the song is partly inspired
by his wife haley relationships for
anybody are
they they're really they're they're hard
to navigate you know it's a constant
dance
if you will and yeah i think being
inspired by my relationship has
definitely produced some
some great music
it's important to me that like i'm
singing about kind of what i'm living
first kind of deal like you know for me
i was talking to haley this morning it's
like she's to my priority before
anything else
i'm a pisces before his new single
dropped bieber teased his new video with
a behind the scenes look in this silly
short uh which is currently trending by
the way at number three on youtube